Speaker 1: Trump 2024 may be dying before
it even starts in multiple new 2024 Republican
polls.
Ron DeSantis is leading Donald Trump, and
this is before Trump makes his big announcement
tonight, which we will talk about in a moment.
There are two arguments about the importance
of this, which we will talk about in a moment.
First and foremost, there is a YouGov America
poll, and it asked Republicans, do you prefer
DeSantis or Trump in 2024?
Republicans and Republican leaners say 42%.
Ron DeSantis 35%.
Donald Trump 10% neither.
13%.
Not sure.
Now the neither and the not sure could make
the difference and push it back to Trump.
But we are now for the first time getting
these types of numbers.
This poll was conducted November 9 to 11,
meaning it was after the 2022 midterm, and
indeed it would be a logical causation to
infer, although for now we can say it's a
correlation, it could be a causation that
Trump's controversial and sort of like contested
endorsements in 2022 that went bad.
That includes Carrie Lake, although we didn't
know about that until yesterday, Mehmet Oz,
Doug Mastriano, etc., that the failure of
those endorsements has reinvigorated support
for someone other than Trump.
Now you might say, Well, David served with
total respect and tears in my eyes.
That's only one poll.
Well, there are now multiple polls that show
DeSantis leading.
Yes, there's a new morning consult poll in
which Trump is still winning.
However, we now have a CWC Research poll in
Texas which shows Texas prefers DeSantis over
Trump 43 to 32.
That's a pretty big deal.
We have a Georgia Republican primary poll
from WPA intelligence which shows DeSantis
plus 20 over Trump.
We have one in Florida which shows DeSantis
plus 26 over Trump.
New Hampshire.
DeSantis plus 15.
Iowa, DeSantis plus 11.
And one from the Association for Canadian
Studies for a general national primary, which
shows DeSantis plus two.
This splits.
This changed right after November 8th.
Now, there's two arguments here.
Argument.
One is that this is all completely irrelevant.
The argument that it's irrelevant is.
If you actually have Trump and DeSantis running
an ugly, contested, snippy primary against
each other, Trump will do the same sort of
stuff that he did in 2016, making fun of people,
ridiculing them, being Teflon, and that ultimately
DeSantis isn't going to be able to do it and
that DeSantis is going to fall off.
There are some major differences, however.
Number one.
If indeed this is a two candidate race, Trump
versus DeSantis, that's very different than
what would have happened than what did happen
in 2015 and 2016, which was you had 18 candidates
or 19 candidates to start with.
You had a lot of these ones and twos people
polling one and 2%, and Trump just would stick
it out long enough for one of the ones and
twos to fall off.
And Trump picks up a point, and then another
one of the ones and twos falls off and Trump
picks up another point or two.
There was this attrition sort of dynamic.
If you just start with really just two candidates
in 2024, Trump and DeSantis, with Trump being
a known political entity, with Trump already
being president, with Trump already losing
himself in 2020 and hurting Republicans in
22, you can argue the circumstances are so
different that it is not going to be a similar
situation.
But for the first time, the betting markets
now pointing to DeSantis over Trump in the
primary and increasingly polling pointing
to DeSantis over Trump.
Tonight is the big announcement.